[Music]
a couple of guys
they see a vehicle
off the side of the road and it has a
free car
written in the free car free car
bait car for sure the door open and
everything he was unlocked keys he's
inside
blood stains dead body
some things are too good to be true so
they get in the and they get in their
free car is this a mr beast video no
unfortunately
it just ends there and then mr beast
climbs out of the trunk and gives them a
mansion no
no what happens is they discover after
driving around for a couple hours that
there was a dead body in the trunk oh
my god
they called it anthony i can't believe
they didn't inspect the whole [ __ ] and
it says free car
like is this a killer that's also a
jokester yeah
this guy's got a great sense of the
headline on the news oh it's pac-man
young man fine free car with dead body
do you think they killed somebody
through in the back and then when they
got in trouble they're like
well the car said free car hey but the
real question is though
after they took the body out do they get
to keep the car
no it's police evidence because they get
to keep the bodies
no yeah they can't keep the carpet
i found the gun that killed the person
uh after the court tried to have the gun
back
hey
fair question
is a fair question where does the gun go
just in an evidence locker forever yeah
if it's just gonna sit there i might as
well get some use out of it that's true
it goes missing in a couple of years
if the case is closed and we lock the
guy up you know no anne's ifs or budget
there's just a gang of people waiting at
the back of courthouses for that sale
every time the end of the day oh they
need to do an auction yeah like an
auction for that [ __ ] evidence stars
yeah hey another this might be a dumb
question but i'm asking anyway does that
car get haunted afterwards
that's not a dumb question that's true
you have to sage it and then it won't
get hot
yeah how does haunting work is it where
the person got killed yes or where they
got transported that's where they got
killed so like what if he got killed in
the backyard and then they threw him in
the car
then the car's not haunted the backyard
is i'm sure there's carryover i think
that's part of the radius yeah yeah so
it's it's if you got killed in the house
and then you're put in the car then i
think that it goes wherever it's like in
those two things now he's absolutely
right is there a gps for the point of
death right so if you got strangled in
the car that's moving wherever the car
was while it was moving is where you
hung on the gps coordinates yes okay so
if it's like mile marker 55 on the on
the freeway that's where you're going to
haunt that's why there's that lady in
the taxi
you know they always the late at night
they go they they look back or they pick
somebody up and then it's like drove by
that spot and that [ __ ] got killed on
the street there what if it's the kind
where the car smashes the person into
the tree and when he backs up the upper
bodies on the car and the legs are on
the tree oh
the point of hunting the tree or the car
that keeps driving that the hood of the
car would be haunted and so with the
tree yeah both of them would be point of
haunting is where the deceased but then
when you like take a hike around that
tree area you're just gonna see [ __ ]
legs walking around only oh that's why
there's the no upper body ghost exactly
the floating ones with the fall torso
yes yes yes yes we've all seen those
we've seen these those are popular sorry
back to the article
how come items get haunted though items
things ghostly items yes that's the most
absurd thing i've ever heard like this
could be haunted right now an item
objects inanimate like a mirror i'll
take a mirror home you never seen
annabelle the [ __ ]
doll i didn't watch it their spirit has
to go into it
the satanic spirit has exercised from
one thing and put in to kill it's like
the corona virus it's like uh it's like
a horse like the corona buyer it's like
voldemort
he who must not be named you know he
splits his soul puts it into a bunch of
random stuff puts it in different places
difficult to get that makes sense thank
you for the context and why are always
the objects so scary like why can't they
just like hot tabasco yeah everything is
always like this old dog
this old rag doll you go so you need to
figure out some new [ __ ] right yeah yeah
it's always to be fair old house to be
fair though like before the whole
stereotype of the ragdoll got haunted
that's not a ragdoll is not scary oh so
it's chicken in the egg kind of thing
yeah it became scary so if it does hunt
plants later on plants probably would be
scary yeah i get that that's true so
that's just universally scary so police
are investigating
police are investigating which part of
the car is haunted just to answer your
question okay but the body was
identified as a 34 year old man named
anthony mcrillis his body had been in
there for several days and was found
naked
he was identified through his tattoos
and confirmed through his immediate
family oh so no smells while they were
driving they noticed when they had
driven from one county to another and
they
checked the trunk because they got
pretty hard i would technically do the
same i wouldn't like inspect it where it
was i would like make sure i can grab it
and nobody else knows it and then i
would be like all right is it worth
having why don't you take pictures of it
first yeah and then
open up everything it's like a rental
car all right i would do i would have
respect the whole thing
and then i would take the free car sign
off and take the keys and then park
somewhere else and watch if people come
and approach this car to see like who
this car belongs to yeah the kids
joyriding in it they are murder suspects
now so it sounds like you could just do
this whole thing to yourself to get off
you could just go you can make the sign
yourself after killing a dude and going
hey i just saw a free car sign man oh
that's a slick move which is maybe what
these youngsters did is that where you
get into and then now they're just
getting
now they're getting time for
a a suspect not really getting nailed
for the actual crime oh wow
we don't know but the free car was
registered to the kid's name and that's
where they [ __ ] up yeah it's a big
[ __ ] up right there that's a tv show
though we got a tv show we gotta figure
out the ending let's try to figure out
the ending that's just the pilot so you
don't need any right just cliffhanger
yeah a show about free things that are
actually like [ __ ] up every episode
every episode is like yeah
there's always a naked dead guy in it
nothing is free that's the premise of
it's like [ __ ]
there's always a price but at what cost
i know yeah
the show is very derivative says says
every reviewer
you can see it coming a mile away
but uh they basically say they don't
know what happened to the guy he was
last seen on home for surveillance video
friday night they found the car
saturday
uh four days or the next saturday
and they don't know what happened to the
guy but they're doing an autopsy to find
out i wonder if he got choked to death
if only dead people can talk he's butt
naked too they strip down more reason to
be choked
wait what sexy it's like naked it's not
an invite to choke me
it's like a [ __ ] psa
let's go to one of those korean spas you
see someone naked oh my god
hey yo
[Laughter]
i was like oh [ __ ] this guy's choking me
because you're naked now wouldn't it be
cool if uh dna you could like save like
a message before you die or some [ __ ]
and then they could pick that chip from
you like an away message on your aim
it's like that uh that
yeah this [ __ ] choked me to
death yeah watch this
you don't even identify who
this guy oh it's like a 90s voicemail
where you got to find some voice to
men's song first and you play oh so this
guy [ __ ] killed me
what's up everybody i'm getting choked
right now please leave a message yeah
837.
you guys seen the um they have
tombstones now where they have video
played qr codes right yeah yeah so you
see that's cool yeah in japan they have
these qr codes on their tombstone and
it's like a video of like they're live
and it's like yeah oh
sorry okay for something i thought it
was something completely what were you
thinking about the murder it's like you
scan it and then like their bust pops
out and they're like hey my name was
blah blah blah
oh that is cool too oh [ __ ] i want to
put a bunch of clues to my murder as my
thing and even though i would died of a
[ __ ] heart attack or something just
like so you so you made it to step three
in my murder mystery the tombstone yeah
yeah dude let me tell you they say i had
a heart attack but i suspect i'll play
yeah
remember follow the money or ask my mom
[Applause]
[Music]